[Music]
this episode is sponsored by Squarespace
go to squarespace.com microcosmos to
save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain
[Music]
hi I'm Matt and I'm not really new here
I've been a producer for Journey to the
microcosmos from the very beginning
editing videos for the first few years
of the channel and keeping our journey
running smoothly and some of you maybe
have even seen me in our live streams
but this is New Right me talking to you
all I'll probably be around a bit more
along with some other new voices as our
usual voice Hank take some time to take
care of himself so our journey will
sound a bit different maybe even look a
bit different at times but every Journey
has to take unfamiliar paths and we hope
you'll enjoy this one with us and like I
said I spent the first few years of this
channel editing the videos together
and in that time I've gotten so much
better at identifying our microbial
friends than I ever would have imagined
like these organisms before I worked on
this show if you'd asked me what they
are I maybe would have told you that
they look like some long threads
but we've seen them quite a bit now
watching them Glide across our slides as
we talk about their sediment homes and
that's how I know that these are a type
of bacteria called bejiatoa
things that give them away first is the
simple Serpentine shape of their bodies
sliding against each other like a pile
of pythons buried on a microscopy Slide
the second detail that identifies them
as begiatoa are those little dots inside
of them they look like bubbles but
they're actually sulfur granules so why
do our veggietoa friends stuff
themselves full of sulfur
to understand that we have to first talk
about where they live James our master
of microscopes usually finds his
begiatoa at the bottom of his fish tank
where their accumulated bodies turn the
sediment White
and in the wild veggietoa can be found
in both freshwater and Marine
environments layering themselves upon
each other to form mats that can end up
looking like Nature's weirdest shag rug
they gather in the area of water that
will give them access they need a
particular nutrients but what does that
mean exactly we all like to live in a
spot that gives us the access we need to
particular nutrients but we don't all
form clumps and mats on the bottom of
fish tanks so what is it about their
particular location that particularly
suits the veggietoa
the answer came in the year 1887 from a
scientist named Sergey winogradsky
winogratzky is sometimes credited with
discovering veggietoa but from what
we've read scientists have been
describing and studying vegetoa before
he did in 1870 one researcher described
the fact that those granules would
increase in number when the begiatoa was
in its normal habitat there was
something about these sulfur granules
that made sense given that these veggie
Attila were found in sulfur-rich
environments like Sulfur Springs and
when other scientists began to look at
bacteria in those environments they
found similar granules
but the creation and purpose of those
granules remained unclear winogratsky
did not first encounter vegeto with the
intention of solving those mysteries in
1885 he began working for the botanist
Anton DeBerry at the University of
Strasbourg the question that winogransky
was initially meant to pursue revolved
around the shape of bacteria and really
just how fixed that shape is to answer
that question when a grasky began
traveling around Switzerland and Germany
to gather begiatoa growing in Sulfur
Springs but then he got a bit distracted
and wandered down a different path when
agrasky needed to figure out how to keep
the veggietoa he was studying alive in
the lab so he grew them in tiny little
cultures and watched as the vegetoa
filaments stuck to the side of their
Chambers he would watch them with
various fluids with different
compositions and as he watched them he
could begin to see what nutrients best
sustain the vegetoa and as he watched
when agradsky's curiosity around the
sulfur granules grew as he asked more
and more questions about how they got
inside the organisms and what their role
is
in one of his experiments when agrathki
kept different batches of cells in
different types of spring water and then
monitored them under the microscope he
found that the cells grown in the
presence of hydrogen sulfide would end
up full of those sulfur granules but
cells grown in Spring Water full of
calcium sulfate didn't that experiment
showed that the vegetable were getting
their sulfur granules by oxidizing
hydrogen sulfide this also explains how
the bacteria find their ideal spot in
the water a narrow band were hydrogen
sulfide and oxygen are both present and
that allows begiatoa access to both
chemicals they need to form those sulfur
granules but this still didn't explain
what the vegetoa do with the sulfur
granules when a gradsky could see that
when the begiatoa were deprived of
hydrogen sulfide those granules would
disappear
so
where did they go
were they released into the environment
were they absorbed by the cell in some
way
what was the point of the sulfur
[Music]
what winogradsky found is that the
sulfur was essentially food for the
vegetoa fueling their cellular
respiration this was the first ever
description of what would later be known
as chemolithotrophy and it was
groundbreaking it meant that winogradsky
had found an organism that could draw
energy from an inorganic compound in
this case using sulfur to drive the
reactions it needs to produce energy
eventually scientists discovered more
organisms that could use sulfur in this
way as well as others that relied on
different inorganic compounds like
nitrogen and in doing so they are able
to convert these chemicals into
biological forms that can travel through
ecosystems and then back into the
environment for sulfur that Journey will
take it through many lives as part of
rocks and amino acids and even acid rain
Transforming Our Lives and landscapes in
the process
organisms like vegetoa Usher sulfur
through that Odyssey a mundane Act of
consumption that shapes our entire world
and so perhaps it's fitting to end with
winogradsky's own words a moment from
his Memoir where he describes the moment
of discovery
the work was humdrum it dragged on and
on sluggishly and all of a sudden it
developed into an interesting result
that was finished all the beating around
suddenly made sense
and I matured in my own eyes even so
I could not see that my Discovery would
become an Epoch making Discovery would
determine the course of all my future
work and that it would open a new
chapter in microbiology and physiology
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us and thank you to
Squarespace for sponsoring this episode
Squarespace offers an incredible online
platform from which to create your
website whether you're a budding
entrepreneur or looking to expand your
current Venture Squarespace provides all
the necessary tools to help you thrive
maybe you have a passion for Gourmet
baking and want to establish an
impressive online presence for your
bakery Squarespace enables you to craft
a visually stunning and professional
website that showcases your delectable
creations and embodies your unique brand
with their comprehensive Suite of
features including third-party
extensions you can effortlessly manage
your inventory simplify bookkeeping and
ship your baked goods worldwide and if
you want to share your baking journey
and engage with fellow baking
enthusiasts Squarespace makes it a
breeze to create a seamlessly integrated
blog alongside your bakeries online
store you can Captivate your readers by
sharing your latest recipes baking tips
and behind the scenes insights into your
creative process and you can engage in
meaningful conversations with your
clientele through threaded comments and
replies cultivating a passionate
community of baking enthusiasts
start building your online Bakery today
by signing up for a free trial at
squarespace.com and when you're ready to
launch don't forget to visit
squarespace.com microcosmos to enjoy a
10 discount on your first purchase of a
website or domain experience the power
of Squarespace and watch your bakery
business rise to new heights
those names you're seeing on the screen
right now are names of our patreon
patrons they are some of the people who
support this Channel and keep it going
so if you enjoy the fact that this show
has existed for four years now you can
drop a little thank you in the comments
to those patreon patrons but you can
also become one of them and support the
channel directly at patreon.com journey
to micro
if you'd like to see more from our
Master microscopes James Weiss you can
check out jam and germs on Instagram and
if you'd like to see more from us well
there's probably a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
probably below the video or on the
screen right now one of those two just
click it and it'll that it works